[Applause]
i'm watching cobra kai and there's this
fine ass little boy in that [ __ ]
shower
there is there is in the [ __ ] there
is in the show no no no no
we are leaving this all in here
don't cut that out leave that [ __ ] in
you feel that feel that
let him feel it okay ready
should we rewind right now running back
in the edit
i'm saying in the edit i want you to
repeat the joke again for everybody
that's messed up so i'm watching cobra
kai
all right okay yeah we already talked
about this okay
there's this actor isn't as important
don't leave me now don't leave me now i
don't know
don't leave me now okay yo listen this
flanker won right now please
please look at how old this this
fine ass human being is hey hey just go
to the imdb page and see if you can
guess who we're talking about
just look how old he is not miguel
that little white boy look at that hello
that little white boy robbie
how old is he just make sure he's over
18. wait his name is robbie
no his character's name is robbie in the
show
the cobra kai is the name of the show
tanner buchanan look how
old he is okay i need to know this
before i continue this intense
how old 21. knew that [ __ ] was
legal
i knew he was legal now come get this
sexual harassment
all right let me tell you this little
topanga looking [ __ ] out here
all right this man this dude made me
feel weird bro
the first scene he got this little bob
haircut yeah
okay perfect straight thick luscious
hair that dude right there
mark just set your ass up he just turned
18.
no
[Applause]
bro i just i looked this [ __ ] up right
here just set you up it's [ __ ]
barely legal son what is he how old is
he says 21 on wikipedia 21 wikipedia
that's what we going with all right
all right okay stop looking up barely
legal.com for [ __ ] information bro
to be turned into this dude he said yeah
that's the character [ __ ]
character
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
yo how old is wolverine yo wolverine's
tech gives me 233 because he ate
faster when you recover
guys
it got his whole family in the bio don't
take it away
he's got his whole family in his bio
his teacher is danny larusso
come on bro i don't know man love
interest samantha larusso anyway
back to what i'm saying okay this kid
shows up first scene
yeah got this little bob haircut mad
feminine mad to pangos yeah looking like
a prettier mark
looking like a pretty nice look like
mark brown you said that that [ __ ] made
me feel uncomfortable
because i was i was bringing to the
table how cute that [ __ ] was
so this is what happened the other day
we're at the table just discussing the
show
[ __ ] felt mad weird so at the table
discussing the show right i'm like yo
i'm watching this cobra car
i was like let me tell you this is one
character on that show and out of
nowhere
archives goes you had a cute one and i'm
about to be like yeah
and then i'll just go [ __ ] look
just like mark and i was like
mark brown that's me no [ __ ]
balls like that look at his collarbone
look at
[Applause]
[Applause]
look at that brown he got a normal ass
brow
not normal he's trying to froze if that
was mark there'd be a shadow on his
shoulder place right now you know
damn bro that's not [ __ ] mark okay
oh
a little bit hold on now maybe it is
cross your arms a little bit
oh [ __ ] bruh oh [ __ ] it's a little cute
ass
yeah what y'all doing all these late
nights tomorrow bro you just gotta raise
this [ __ ] right here looks
feminine does he not
look at the haircut all right he's
twenty-one he's gonna look through the
haircut
i think he just wanna [ __ ] him so you
try to make him look feminine
all i know is the first scene that i saw
yeah this is what happens i'm watching
with my girl
and we're watching the show and he pops
up and i literally
i literally go like this i go i go
son hold on i don't worry about waiting
for the first heat
the first time he pops up on his screen
right
he's all like he's all like a little
confused like
a little deer in headlights little look
and i just go i just go
man come on
hey yo my body didn't know what to
do
because i was like well i couldn't
explain it bro
i felt like jk rowling that's why she
that's why she write those books wait
why
little training kid right here making
you feel weird
not the harry potter book what
what avina cadabra bro get the [ __ ] out
of here i had enough of this kid oh my
god oh my god
you can't deny he's objectively cute for
a boy
he is trying to get you in that
you